if you are on the outside looking in
you'd be like this guy's this guy's got
a good life but on the inside I was
dying it was like this whole time I'd
been trying to jam this square peg into
a round hole I was deeply dissatisfied
with my career choices it was feeling
like a low-grade depression I wasn't
taking care of myself physically I put
on all this weight and terrible
lifestyle habits is this the rest of my
life that's rich roll he's an ultra
endurance athlete author of the
best-selling book finding ultra and with
more than 25 million downloads he's got
one of the most popular podcasts in the
world
in our conversation we talked about the
huge risks he took early on how he deals
with pain and also how he became one of
the 25 most fit men in the world you're
listening to the ground up show a
podcast that inspires creatives to make
meaningful content and pursue their
passion my name is Matt Dee Avella and
I'm a filmmaker best known for the
Netflix documentary minimalism and I'm
sitting down with creators to talk about
their process the lessons they've
learned on how to make an impact
[Music]
rich thanks for being here I appreciate
it yeah thank you for having me
so we were talking a little bit before
the podcast started about some of the
video stuff you're doing it seems like
you're you're making moves there and
you're starting to be really consistent
with it have you always done video I
wouldn't say that I've always done video
I've always been interested in video in
fact but long before any of the stuff
that I do now I was getting into
filmmaking and writing I wrote and
directed a short film that did the
festival circuit in 2005 and even won
some awards so yeah I was called down
dog it was a satire on the LA yoga scene
it's up on Vimeo you can check it out
it's like a 22 minute short that I shot
on 35 millimeter with a full crew and
the whole thing so and and I went to I
did a summer intensive filmmaking
program at NYU back in 1990 1991 or 1992
so I've always been interested in film
I've peed on movies and things like that
I open up a youtube account you know
probably 2008 and started doing a little
bit of stuff here and there but never
really fully invested in it and then I
did I took a stab at making a couple
vlogs like you know over the last two
years and really enjoyed that and I love
editing and I love storytelling but I
just couldn't do it on my own you know I
just needed help because it was just
overwhelming and it was eclipsing the
other things that I was working on which
is why I brought on David I've always
been looking for a collaborative partner
so that I could step into the video
space and in a meaningful way and do it
sustainably as so much of my time today
is spent in editing I'm wondering should
I like I feel like I needs to hire
somebody because there's other stuff
that needs to be done like I'm trying to
build a podcast I'm trying to keep an
audience engaged and keep them
interested in what I'm making mmm and
yes you have to do the work but I feel
like it's not sustainable long term to
keep turning out these videos that take
8 to 10 hours to write but you're a
filmmaker like this is what you do like
you could justify that time investment
but I'm writing books and I'm doing all
these other things and but I love the
medium like I made this silly little
video maybe a year and a half ago called
vegan on $25.00 where I just spent a day
going to different markets and seeing
what you could buy for 25 bucks and I
pulled an all-nighter to edit that thing
like I literally stayed up all night I
I'm pulling an all-nighter in 10 or 15
years you know and I came home at like
9:00 in the morning and my wife was like
what are you doing and I was like I got
obsessed I was like every little cut you
know and that video is now has like two
hundred and seventy thousand views it's
the most viewed thing that I've done on
YouTube so it's gratifying in that sense
but I'm like I can't this this is not
what I'm still like this is not what I'm
supposed to be doing how do you approach
that perfectionism where I know
sometimes I'll just get caught up on a
video and it's like every single edit
I'm like re I'm probably spending way
too much time looking at the details but
like sometimes it's that video that
takes off gets 200,000 views and it
really has an impact so it's like how do
you know when to justify putting in the
time I don't I don't know well I don't
do that well I'm a perfectionist to a
fault which is a strength and also very
much an Achilles heel and I carry that
into the podcasting that I do in the
writing and everything that I do and it
makes me a bit of a control freak and I
think ultimately it caps my growth you
know so my journey has been about
learning to focus on the things that I
do best that other people can't do and
learning to let go and empower other
people around me to do you know to do
the other tasks and that's challenging
for me because I want to have my paws on
everything and and you know that idea
like oh only I can do it you know that's
just an ego driven thing that will just
drive your business in your life into
the ground it's easy to get caught up in
what other people are doing to you see
somebody else make an amazing video or
you see them doing a podcast in a
specific way and you're like maybe I
should do that maybe I should change it
up you know it's really interesting to
track that in both podcasting and
YouTube you know when Casey came on the
scene and started vlogging like he
reinvented that genre in a beautiful way
but then so many people have mimicked
that and copied that and so the real
question is what's next like where's the
white space what people what are people
not do
where is there a need or a void that can
be filled and you know I'm my podcast I
started it it's been five years so I
wouldn't say that I was an early adopter
of the medium because it was online in
2006 or whatever I started in 2012 but
it wasn't cool to have a podcast started
you know the growth of this medium has
exploded just in the last two years
alone and it's really become kind of the
new blog and I've stuck to my guns and
have enough experience now to know how
to do it the way that I want to do it
and I don't spend a lot of time paying
attention to what other people are doing
but I am trying to evolve with it as
well and you know we're in a video
culture so my you know evolution that we
were talking about just before we
started this was stepping into video and
like how can I do something creative and
interesting in that space that isn't
copycatting but it's also capturing you
know the wisdom and the experience of
the guests that I have on and
translating it in a way that's dynamic
to an audience that isn't necessarily
listening to podcasts on their iPhone
you know I mean I think the YouTube
audience and the podcast the audience if
you drew a Venn diagram they overlap but
they're also very different yeah that's
when I saw you start to do the video and
brought on David to start making these
really high quality beautiful videos and
also filming your entire podcast
episodes I was like damn it that was
like that's what I thought was like
making me unique because I haven't seen
anybody doing it that way whereas they
will be soon yeah it's gonna it's gonna
happen do you see anybody today doing at
that level there's a lot of documenting
and there's a lot of kind of crappy
camcorder type you know visuals that
correspond with that go along with
podcasting but I haven't seen anybody
elevate it to an art form yet and you
know with you I mean look the minimalism
documentary you made is amazing like I
love that movie like you're gifted and
talented I've no doubt that that what
you're creating now and will create or
what this will evolve into will probably
set the bar for that but I think that's
the next that's the white space right so
there's there's people videoing there
gasps with GoPros and camcorders but how
can you do it in how can you elevate
that medium and make it a little bit
more interesting so a big part of this
podcast it's called the ground up show
so it's going back and kind of
deconstructing how you got here how you
started the podcast how you got into
fitness and everything in between
back in college when you're thinking
about going out into the quote-unquote
real world what was your idea of success
what did it look like for you my idea of
success at that time was a very
traditional one
you know premise Don the American Dream
you know I grew up upper-middle-class in
Washington DC I went to a private
all-boys high school I wore a coat and
tie I was a good boy I never got in
trouble but I was also a very awkward
insecure kid I had a patch on mine or
the headgear and was the last kid picked
for a kickball and all that kind of
stuff and ultimately found solace and
success in the swimming pool so by the
time I was a senior in high school I was
a top-ranked recruit in in swimming and
got into every college that I applied to
you know I had my pick of the litter and
went to Stanford you know unbelievable
academic institution and also the best
swimming program in the country at that
time
and so I was somebody with a lot of
promise and somebody who grew up in a
household where education was was
paramount and I think you know not
explicitly but there was expectations
both placed on me and internally driven
to like live up to the opportunities
that I was lucky enough to have right so
it started out with the idea of being a
doctor you know like I thought that I
always thought I was gonna be a doctor I
was good in biology study that in
college the first couple of years but
but you know really my collegiate years
are mostly about my introduction to
alcohol and that and that was something
that was new to me at the time I didn't
I wasn't partying in high school I was
swimming but when I when I got to
college partying and having
time really took center stage and
started to really put a drain on my
ambitions and I lost interest in in the
sciences and shifted my major and
ultimately by the time I graduated like
I just where's my next good time I never
really put a lot of thought into what I
wanted to be or what was unique about me
or what made me happy all of that energy
was was in swimming and when swimming
was over I was like well I never really
thought about what I wanted to do all I
wanted to do was party so like I moved
to New York City because it seemed like
a great place to get drunk and then law
school just seemed like well that's what
you do when when you know you have this
pedigree that I had and you're not sure
what you want to do my dad's a lawyer he
loves being a lawyer but it was never
like he wanted me he never put any
pressure on me to be a lawyer it was
almost like a default thing well that's
a good career path it's safe you know
you get to wear a nice suit and go out
to nice lunches and talk about
intellectual things like that sounds
good you know listen it wasn't driven by
a passion for the law or some desire to
right wrongs or you know kind of an
innate desire to to to pursue justice or
anything like that so it was about like
being safe being secure not taking risks
you know that was very much my mindset
was there any other options for you at
the time at least that as you saw him
well it was different I mean when I
graduate from college I was in 1989 this
is pre-internet you know I had that old
Macintosh you know little the original
Macintosh computer and I remember like
going to the career like the career
counselors like building at Stanford and
you think this is Stanford like you know
they must have like all kinds of
interesting opportunities for people and
it was just brochures for consulting
companies and you could sign up to get
interviewed by these investment banks
but it was pretty limited it was like
consulting and Investment Banking and
being a paralegal in a law firm like it
seemed like those were the only options
which is weird like the idea that you
could go online and that this whole
world would open up to you where you
could explore all these different
interesting compelling dynamic career
paths as a young person I didn't I
couldn't find that I did I
it didn't seem like it was available to
me I'm sure it was but you know and I'm
sure I didn't look very hard either but
I just sort of took the path of least
resistance I suppose I'm curious about
the transitions in your life because you
go from college to joining a law firm
and then from the law firm to doing
freelance and then freelance to fitness
and being an author and podcaster like
those transitions to me are fascinating
because they're terrifying
and they seem incredibly risky so you
must have been making pretty good money
as a lawyer and building a career in LA
yeah I mean right after college I worked
at a law firm in New York City as a
paralegal which was a horrible
experience a big wall street law firm
and I just you know the people who were
working there I was like a large didn't
it didn't resonate with me at all and
it's shocking to me now in retrospect
that I that I went to law school after
that experience but it was like well
that's what you do and I went to law
school and somehow squeaked my way
through that despite you know the fact
that my alcoholism was really starting
to cause problems in my life got a job
at a law firm in San Francisco then
moved down to Los Angeles to work in an
entertainment firm and that's where the
[ __ ] kind of hit the fan in terms of my
alcoholism and my life fell apart at
that time and that's a whole other story
I'm happy to get into if you want but
ultimately got sober at 31 and the next
eight years was about trying to repair
all the wreckage that I'd created as a
result of my drinking and using and I
kind of took all of that compulsive
addict alcoholic energy and invested it
in workaholism and I was successful in
our in that regard by the time I was 38
39 years old successful legal career
living in Los Angeles met my wife
building a family decent income all the
good stuff like all the stuff you know
like nice sports car and and if you were
on the outside looking in you'd be like
this guy's this guy's got a good life
but on the inside I was dying it was
like this whole time I'd been trying to
jam this square peg into a round hole I
was deeply dissatisfied with my career
choices it was fueling like a low-grade
depression I wasn't taking care of
myself physically I put on all this
weight and terrible lifestyle habits and
all of that and I was desperate to try
to figure out
how am I going to is this the rest of my
life you know I've looked around in the
law firm where I worked and I didn't
aspire to the lives of the partners they
all were making great money and we're
successful and some of them really
enjoyed what they did and and good
people but I just didn't I was like I
don't see myself in that role but I was
trying to force it you know I was like
denying who I was at my core because
I've never really looked at that and
explored like well Who am I what is it
that I'm here to express and what is
unique about me and what makes me happy
like those weren't questions I asked
myself nor was I ever encouraged to ask
myself and it really was sort of
fomenting into this existential crisis
like and you know I've only changed my
life as a result of being in pain you
know that's been the only true motivator
to get me to shift my ways and it wasn't
an overnight thing I mean there's a lot
of things that came into play and it was
a long road in many years of trying to
recalibrate my professional career in my
personal career and it wasn't easy like
I I didn't stop practicing law until the
day my first book came out so I was
practicing law and writing a book and
training for all these ultra distance
events that none of which was really
generating any money you know and kind
of slowly escalating out of what was
then a solo law practice I was no longer
in a big law firm but still couldn't see
the path forward you know how am I going
to even though I wrote a book and got
paid to write that book it wasn't enough
to support a family with four kids like
how am I going to craft a career based
on the things that I was slowly learning
you know that I was passionate about and
that I had a voice and a platform to to
pursue there was no template for how to
do that and it was I had to like craft
it out of whole cloth I think in it and
and it wasn't it wasn't linear by any
stretch of the imagination it doesn't
seem like there is a template now even
today to say these are the steps that
you have to take in order to get where
you want to go no I mean for me it was
very much like a leap of faith gets
thrown around very cavalierly but it but
it was I was like I'm not practicing law
anymore
I have no idea where
I'm gonna my next paycheck is gonna come
from I don't know how that's gonna work
at all but I trusted that I knew myself
well enough and I knew the feedback that
I was getting from the book was potent
enough to say there is something here
like if I fully devote myself to
figuring this out like I will I will
figure it out and I don't know what
that's gonna look like and you know it
was we went through some very difficult
financial times and we almost lost our
house like I risked everything and I put
a tremendous amount of strain on my
family my wife always had my back she
was like you're not going back to being
a lawyer like this is what you have to
do like you just have to stay the course
and without that support I'd never would
have been able to do it but it was
really just showing up every day trying
to pay attention what can I do and it
was being in it was just being in
service like what can I offer well I'll
write this blog post or I'll go give
this talk or I'll go do this none of
which I was getting paid for the podcast
I began I did it for two years before I
made a single dollar on it like I just
did it because it just seemed like a way
to continue the conversation that my
book began I didn't start it as a
thinking it was going to be some kind of
professional enterprise it was just
something I felt strongly about I felt
called to do and I think the lesson that
I've learned as a result of that is that
if you've done the internal work to
really know yourself and what you're
passionate about and you can if you can
have the courage and the faith to step
into that that indeed the universe will
conspire to support you and you will
find your way and it doesn't mean that
it's gonna work out the way that you
want it to work out or think that it's
gonna work out and your timeline is not
gonna be the timeline that you know that
that's gonna play out but my experience
is that by but by remaining steadfast
that that is how I was able to see it
through and be able to sit here and talk
to you today yeah I believe pretty
heavily in calculated risks so I
graduated college with 96 thousand
dollars in student loan debt and then I
did the smartest thing I could think of
I bought a brand new car that is about a
hundred eighteen thousand dollars in
debt so I was in no place to just risk
it all and I guess risk it affects
everybody a little bit differently some
people can take risks a little bit more
easily than others
but I think that's probably one of the
biggest things is that what can you
stomach how like how little can you live
on can you live on rice and beans or the
next two years trying to make it work
probably most people are not willing to
take enough risk and they're also not
willing to do the work or what it takes
to achieve that life like they don't
want to live on rice and beans they
don't want to sell their car or you know
they want to be able to maintain their
lifestyle and and like live the dream
occupation and I think you have to be
willing to sacrifice quite a bit if
that's what you want and ultimately you
know my experience is that and this is
I'm sure you know this from you know
being in the world of the minimalist
like this when when you're actively
engaged in something you love doing that
is personally fulfilling to you all that
other stuff doesn't mean anything
anymore when I was making a bunch of
money and I was miserable I would just
obsess on like what am I gonna get you
know I want I need a new suit or I need
like this pair of shoes or it was all
about like what am I gonna buy to make
me feel better because I wasn't even
aware of how much I was suffering and I
felt like that would be that would make
me that would that would sell that won't
on an unconscious level and now that I
get to do whatever what I like doing and
I'm fulfilled in that like I don't think
about stuff it seems contradictory to a
lot of people to say I want to stop
focusing on the money that's when the
money comes it's kind of ironic how that
happens it's a spiritual equation it
really is because if all you're doing is
making something to in the hopes to get
rich and famous
you're so misguided in your direction
that I don't think you're actually gonna
realize all the ways that that's gonna
affect your art and what you're creating
and what you're putting out in the world
I'm actually curious about as you
evolved and as you started to get into
fitness what was the the tipping point
for you to get into fitness and start
exercising I was pursuing this legal
career I was having this existential
crisis and meanwhile I wasn't as I said
I wasn't taking care of myself
physically 50 pounds overweight and
shortly before I turned 40 this
existential crisis that I was having
sort of collided with with a health
scare I was walking up a simple flight
of stairs up to my bedroom late one
night this is like shortly before I turn
40 and had to pause halfway up halfway
up the staircase like winded out of
breath and tightness in my chest that
had me kind of buckled over and and
really scared you know heart disease
runs in my family my grandfather who had
been a champion swimmer at the
University of Michigan in the late 1920s
had died very young of a heart attack
which devastated my mother I don't think
she's ever really fully recovered from
that and she used to tell me my whole
life like you got to watch what you eat
and heart disease runs in the family but
it's like you know bah bah bah when
you're young you know you don't it's
like in one ear out the other
and having that experience at a young
age and still thinking of myself as like
this fit stanford swimmer even though I
wasn't really woke me up and made me
realize like I really need to
fundamentally change my priorities and
how I'm living and that's what launched
me into this exploration of nutrition
and food and that was something that you
know wasn't overnight either but
ultimately led me to attempting a
plant-based diet because I tried
everything else and nothing seemed to
really work and it was like the one
thing that I had in one box I hadn't
checked yet because I didn't I don't
really want to do it it sounded so
extreme like oh you're gonna no animal
products and no process feel like what's
left to eat like life is over there's
not gonna be any joy anymore but I guess
you know you still want to live right so
I tried it it was an experiment to start
yeah an experiment you know I just was
like I was trying to find a way to feel
good you know in my body like what does
it feel like to have the energy of a
teenager you know is this like what does
it feel like to like want to move your
body like it was something that I just
as a young person like my life was
swimming in fitness and I loved the pool
and I loved competition and I'd moved so
far away from that and that had brought
me so much joy as a young person and I
was trying to recapture that because
that was the one time in my life like
that was something that made me
happy and as you grow older its are like
well that's kids play like now you're an
adult you don't do that anymore but I
was like so desperate to just reconnect
with something that that gave me that
sense once again and within a week or
two of this plant-based diet experiment
I started to feel myself again like I
really had this restoration of vitality
that was pretty profound and that's what
gave me this impulse to start taking
care of myself once again and that
started out very low-key like you know
pulling an old pair of running shoes out
of the closet and going out for a jog
for the first time in a long time or
going back to the pool for the first
time and as long as I could remember and
my wife bought me a bike for my 40th
birthday and you know I I didn't have
any desire to be competitive in sports
anymore I just wanted to like not have a
gut and I wanted to be able to like not
walk around feeling like [ __ ] all the
time really that was it
but I had a couple like breakthrough
moments like the weight was melting off
and I went out for this run one day
after I've been doing this maybe four
months or so and I I just I was like in
the zone man and I ended up doing like a
24 mile run I hadn't run longer than an
hour prior to that and it was a crazy
like watershed moment where I was like
wow like not only is this plant based
diet agreeing with me like I feel like I
just unlocked a part of myself that I
didn't realize that I had and and it got
me thinking a lot about the resiliency
of the human body and spirit which is
something that you know I experienced
going from you know being a pretty
gutter rat trunk into being sober and
and what other areas of my life had I
overlooked and and you know what is the
you know where is the hidden potential
in my life that that I'm blind to right
now and and that's what got me
interested in the world of ultra
endurance sports because it's like this
template to really push that and explore
that so that's what lured me into this
crazy world of doing these you know wild
races that I've done over the years yeah
I want to get into the races I really
want to touch on the
the you tend to shy away from the word
vegan it's kind of become a bad word is
it more plant powered I mean I don't I
don't shy away from it I think that that
yeah whether it's plant base plant out
you know plant power or I like to call
it because it's sort of a positive
affirmative you know way of looking at
it
I don't shy away from the word vegan but
I think the word vegan gets conflated
with politics and I think people have a
certain predisposition or idea of what
being vegan is I think that's changing a
lot now but even like four or five years
ago or in 2012 when my book came out you
know if you if you use the word vegan
everybody has a mental construct of what
that is like it's a it's a dreadlock
dude kicking a hacky sack up at Humboldt
or you know what I mean like which is
cool like but I never identified with
that like I never thought I would be
vegan because I don't like that's not me
like I like those guys I have friends
like that but like that's not my vibe so
plant-based is more neutral plant power
it is more empowering I think but it's
it's it's the same and I and I would say
as a caveat to that that when I began
this journey like you know it wasn't
because I had some deep compassion for
the animals or the environment I really
just want to feel better yeah that was
it I want to lose weight I want to feel
good
plant-based worked for me but the idea
of bringing politics into it didn't seem
like that just wasn't where I was coming
from but having now been somebody who's
lived this lifestyle for the last ten
years like those issues have become much
more important to me yeah and I think
there are things that we need to talk
more about that's exactly how I feel
about minimalism I got into minimalism
because I was personally dissatisfied I
didn't I felt like I would never be
successful I never achieve anything so
it was really personal and kind of
selfish but then once you get into it it
starts to open up these other ideas for
you in terms of the vegan being vegan
and experimenting I actually I started
three days ago my 30-day challenge to
begin yeah so I'm three days in now I
feel pretty good I mean my body's
changing it's pretty clear my body's
changing and I want to go the rich roll
way which is
people have the the false assumption
that you're gonna be weaker by being
vegan and I really like going to the gym
and lifting so I want to get stronger by
the end of the 30 days so I guess what
missteps and might I make in my first
week or so in I think that well yeah I
have to look like get granular on what
exactly you're eating and not eating I
think but in terms of like common
mistakes I think some people if they're
saying they feel weak they're probably
not eating enough calories because
they're used to eating more calorically
dense foods meat and dairy tend to be
that way
so then they go plant-based and they're
just eating salad and they're not
they're just they're just not fueling
themselves with enough food so I would
say don't worry so much about the volume
of food that you're eating if you're
eating plant-based foods close to their
natural state like knock yourself out
these foods are so fiber rich like you
can use as punch as you want and you're
gonna be okay don't worry too much about
the protein thing I mean you want to
make sure you're meeting your protein
needs but you're not gonna have a
problem doing that
just make sure you're eating beans and
lentils and quinoa and things like that
that are higher that you know are higher
in protein in the plant world and I
think you're gonna be fine you don't
have to go nuts with protein powders and
I don't know what you were doing with
that before Josh came over the other day
and he saw the I have this massive
protein yeah yeah and then I he was that
he just was dying laughing cuz he's like
I've never seen a protein thing that big
it's like they wanted like the
bodybuilders on it but the thing is
though when I first got into fitness so
I went from being a hundred and
twenty-five pounds 265 in my like
towards the end of college so I'd always
been a really scrawny guy and then
putting on weight for me with the
protein shakes helped out in the very
beginning like that's how at least in my
eyes I was able to to do it and do it
very easily so it's always been
something that's been a part of my
workout it's like before after it just
kind of becomes a ritual yeah here's
what I would say there's this idea oh
you're going plant-based so you're gonna
be sacrificing your body's ability to be
strong which is a misnomer it's
misguided it's a myth
in fact my experience has been quite the
opposite first of all you're eating
foods that are
much more nutritionally dense like much
more dense in terms of phytonutrients
and micronutrients so you're actually
fueling your body with what it needs
secondarily you're eating foods that are
that are much more alkaline forming and
anti-inflammatory by and large not every
plant food is anti-inflammatory but when
you're eating tons of dark leafy greens
and like healthy fruits and vegetables
you are eating a much more
anti-inflammatory diet than the standard
American diet or even a clean diet that
includes meat and dairy meat and dairy a
very acid-forming they're very
inflammation provoking and this is
important in the context of being an
athlete or performance because the more
anti-inflammatory your diet the more
rapidly your body's going to be able to
recover in between workouts and you know
as somebody who goes to the gym that you
don't make gains in the gym you make
gains in the time in-between your gym
sessions right so the better that you
can take care of yourself in between
workouts through nutrition and other you
know practices we have and all that kind
of stuff the harder you're going to be
able to train in the gym so I would say
that that it's not accurate to say that
eating plant-based makes you a better
athlete or a stronger athlete but it
will allow you to and this is my
personal experience it will allow you to
train harder recover more quickly so
that the next time you go to the gym you
can train harder again or train longer
you're less likely to get injured or get
sick and then miss workouts so over the
course of several months or a year
you're going to experience greater gains
than you would otherwise so it's the
recovery enhancement aspect of eating
plant-based that I think has been almost
a secret weapon for me and I think it's
what allowed me to go from relatively
sedentary to competing in races like
Ultraman in a fairly compressed period
of time in terms of this 30-day
challenge where do you think I might
slip up I know I've done this before but
not to this degree I've done no dairy no
milk cheese and
I will you know be out of the movies and
just you you go into these old routines
where I'm like okay get popcorn and then
sit down and then I'm halfway through my
thing of popcorn and I realize oh [ __ ] I
was not supposed to eat dairy where
where am i I slip up and what do I need
to be prepared for what are your what
are your hot-button foods like what are
your what are your guilty pleasures is
it sugar or is it greasy foods at least
lately it would be some some mochi
before bed or a little bit of ice cream
that stuff I think is kind of easy
because I just won't bring it in the
house Natalie my girlfriend and I we go
out to eat a lot and we go out to a nice
restaurant and we'll usually get a steak
we eat a pretty neat based diet like
that is probably 80% of our diet at this
point well right in your neighborhood
here there are some fantastic
you can restaurants you have Croesus
Madre which is unbelievable you got real
food daily I mean you know there's a
veggie grill that's kind of junk food
that's that's not the healthiest but
it's vegan plenty of opera plenty of
like really nice you know places right
around here some of which are in walking
distance but the greater issue I would
say is is always trying to make the
healthy choice the convenient choice so
it's good to get rid of you know remove
those temptations from arms-length in
your house but always making sure that
you're kind of one step ahead so that
when you are hungry you're not like you
know succumb to that unhealthy craving
so you could do things like just just
get like I don't have a rice cooker or
you just have like rice and beans like
in your fridge you can make like a chili
or like rice and beans with guacamole in
hot sauce you know as always ready there
and you can that will fill you up right
who's got protein it's got carbohydrates
it's got some healthy fats with the
avocado and you're good to go or keeping
things like we're in LA so you know I
don't know about you but like I'm
driving all the time right so I try to
keep healthy snacks in my car
almonds dates bananas just real food so
that I can snack on them and they're
always kind of there so I keep my
appetite at bay and I see you have a
Vitamix in your kitchen oh my god it's
amazing yes unbelievable right so that's
your new best friend and my
know what your habits and practices are
around your Vitamix but I would make
sure that you always have tons of
healthy produce fruits and and dark
leafy greens beets things like that and
what I like to do is start my day with a
like I just pack so much [ __ ] into that
vitamin yeah kale spinach beets are
great pre-workout tons of berries
you know banana pineapple whatever you
have make like a huge blend maybe put a
little coconut oil or something like
that in there and then you don't have to
drink the whole thing like drink a glass
go to I don't if you workout in the
morning go to the gym or whatever and
you can like thermos the rest or keep
the rest and sip it throughout the
morning and it keeps your energy really
high like you feel good like like you
know how it is when you have when you
make that blend and you drink it in the
morning you can almost feel like
yourself coming alive like because
because it blends it so well it's almost
predigested so it's very easily absorbed
into your system and you can feel that
boost of energy very quickly and so if
you're just kind of hitting on that
throughout the morning or even in the
afternoon it keeps your appetite at bay
and it keeps your energy high and that
way when you sit down for mealtime
you're not like overeating or prone to
eat that thing that you know you're not
supposed to eat or shouldn't mean I'm
trying to make the perfect recipe and
simple recipe but it's been challenging
I'd focus more on the blending and less
on the juicing and I wouldn't get caught
up in the perfect recipe like you know
there's like seven people living in my
house every time I open up the fridge
it's like who knows what's gonna be in
there you know so it's like I just make
do with whatever we happen to have and
yeah there's always a way to make
something interesting or good and it's
not always gonna be the best tasting or
like the ultimate you know blend of the
day but you know if you're just putting
lots of fruits and vegetables in there
and rotating it you can get crazy with
superfoods and get spirulina and
chlorella and like chia seeds and flax
seeds and hemp seeds and all those
things are great if you have the budget
for that but you don't need all that
stuff like whose fruits and vegetables
blending it up you're getting so much
fiber which is what most people are
deficient in and you know when we talk
about coming to plant a plant base
everyone's worried about protein but
really nobody's nobody's protein
deficient like
doctors are not treating patients for a
protein deficiency like it's this crazy
weird myth where we believe we need like
tons and tons of protein and yet most
people are walking around fiber
deficient because they're not eating
enough fruits and vegetables and you're
getting a tremendous amount of fiber
which is gonna really boost your immune
system and your digestion and all of
that I've been pretty neurotic lately
with the sleep cycle tracking my sleep
at night it doesn't look like I get
great sleep or at least I just wake up a
lot do you think a plant-based diet will
help with sleep I mean sleeps a weird
thing like I I as I get older or like
I've started to struggle a little bit
with sleep like I'm not training really
hard like III have issues with that
myself and I'm always looking for ways
of like improving that magnesium in your
tea or hot water at night is helpful
some people find CBD oil to be helpful
with that if you're into that kind of
thing is that like marijuana based so
it's it's hemp base it's not
psychoactive it doesn't have that yeah
but it's like a cannabinoid yeah you
know tea not having your devices in your
bedroom all that kind of stuff which is
tough cuz I'm tracking it yeah exactly
it's so bad though cuz that's like the
first thing I'll do when I wake up
you're good and you have anxiety because
you're like what's my tracker so rely
sleeping deep enough wait that's that's
not how it's working at cross-purposes
it really is literally when I wake up I
think like I wonder how my track he's
doing and it's been happening for the
past two weeks so I'm like this is
probably really counterintuitive there's
some TV in but no we actually we haven't
in a while and like TV is in I think the
new thing now wouldn't be TV but just
like bringing your laptop in bed and
watching Netflix we don't do that and
haven't done that for a while which has
helped out a lot but we probably will
watch like Curb Your Enthusiasm or a
show before bed which I would like to
get into the habit of having maybe an
hour of downtime before where I'm not
looking at any screens just like a
morning routine I think you have to have
some kind of night routine yes prepare
you for bed for sure
I remember one part in your book where
you were training and you you felt like
- in order to prepare for this race yet
coming up you had to train harder and
faster and stronger and your trainer
told you to actually do something
contradictory which would be to train
slower
yeah I mean I had been somebody who you
know grew up in swimming and you just go
hard every set go as hard as you can and
then carrying that into being kind of an
amateur athlete I have an hour so I'm
gonna go out and run and I'll just make
the most of the hour I'll run as fast as
I can or whatever I whatever piece I can
sustain for that hour like the way to
get the most out of that time is to push
yourself as hard as you can
it turns out that's counterproductive
especially if you want to you know reach
your potential as an endurance athlete
so in the context of endurance sports
and ultra endurance sports speed really
isn't that important what's important is
efficiency and as my coach says my coach
is two-time Olympic swimmer
he's one man he's age group world
champion in Ironman this guy like knows
what he's talking about he said
something very profound to me which is
the prize doesn't go to the fastest guy
it goes to the guy who slows down the
least and I thought about that and I was
like that's right and that's also true
in life right it's not about how fast
you're going it's like the classic
rabbit in the hair so what he taught me
and what has been really I think key to
my success as an athlete is learning how
to train your aerobic system so we have
two energy burning systems in our in our
bodies the aerobic and the anaerobic the
anaerobic system is that energy system
that your body utilizes for fast bursts
and like in the gym when you're bench
pressing power strength explosive
movements and that energy system runs on
glucose on sugar and it's it's a system
that basically you can maintain for
about 45 minutes before you run out of
glucose or you just burn out all
together your aerobic system relies on
fat and oxygen for fuel it's your go all
day engine it's that low intensity level
of effort that can propel you throughout
the day
so proficiency in endurance sports is
about building that aerobic engine
making it incredible
efficient and you do that by doing a lot
of low threshold work like running far
below that pace that you feel like you
should be running right running so that
you can carry on a conversation when
you're running running at a pace that
when you're new to this feels like
you're not getting anything out of it
and you think you're wasting your time
but in doing that you're building
mitochondrial density you're building
your body's ability to utilize fat for
fuel and do it very efficiently and over
time let's say you start out and you
can't you you you if you get lactate
tested you know exactly what these zones
are it's called soon - by not exceeding
your zone - which for me and running
means my heart I can't go over like 135
or 140 when you start out and you don't
have any experience with this that's
almost like walking you know brisk walk
and then your heart rates spiking if
you're wearing heart rate monitor you're
like this is ridiculous you know I can't
go more than like an 11 minute mile
without my heart but if you stick to it
you know three months later you're doing
a 9 minute mile at that heart rate and
then a year later you're running an
eight minute mile and then before you
know it you're running a seven minute
mile so so in it and it feels like the
same exertion level and you're like
that's profound yeah that's all yeah so
right and it but the thing is it takes
time you know and you have to be patient
with it and you have to really adhere to
it it's not an overnight success it's
not a hack it's the opposite of a hack
actually it requires a lot of time
investment and a lot of diligence and
it's a different kind of discipline like
we think of discipline in the context of
being an athlete as being that impulse
to get you out of bed when you don't
want to get out of bed and go the extra
mile and to be really focused on like
out working your fellow you know
whatever athlete but this discipline
requires you to hold back which is like
contrary to the impulse of the ambitious
athlete right who wants to outwork
everybody and by doing that you create
this amazing foundation that allows you
to run efficiently at faster and faster
speeds at a very low level of energy
output and I think that's what's allowed
me to succeed by like believing in that
and I've
I've like experienced what it's like to
really invest in that the average person
let's say you're a runner they go out
and they're doing like they do that hour
run a 45-minute run and they do it at
that brisk pace as fast as they think
they can and what they're doing it they
think they're getting a good workout in
and on some level they are but
ultimately they're gonna hit a glass
ceiling because when you're doing that
you're not going slow enough to build
your aerobic engine and you're not going
fast enough to build the explosive speed
and power of the anaerobic engine you're
kind of in the middle it's called the
grey zone and so you can reach a certain
level of athletic proficiency by staying
in the grey zone but ultimately you're
never going to progress because you're
in that that that no-man's land that
really isn't focusing on becoming more
adept at either of those two energy
systems would you say it makes your runs
easier it just it helps to push you a
little bit further than you would have
been able to do otherwise well now it
allows me to like run great distances
and and because I've been doing it for
so many years now like I can go out and
run for hours and hours and it just it's
just not that taxing like people are
like oh you must be eating all day long
with all this training you're doing it's
like no actually I like a normal person
because what used to you know eight
years ago have been it would have
required an unbelievable amount of
energy for me to go out and run 20 30
miles now I can do that it's like okay
that's fine like what else is going on
you can like do your emails still when
you're doing these big runs that really
push you you have to be living in so
much pain like what is your relationship
with pain yeah I think I have a high
pain tolerance I mean I learned that as
a swimmer you know learning how to push
your body and kind of maintain that and
it very much becomes a mental thing
because your brain gives out long before
the body the body is in pain it's
sending signals to the brain stop stop
stop but your body can actually go much
further and much longer and much harder
than we think it can usually it's our
brain that shuts it off well before that
and I think the longer that I do this
the more you become in touch with that
there's a there's a endurance athlete
named David Goggins he spent on my
podcast he's personally inspiring to me
and and he said something that's that's
always stuck with me which is that when
you think you're done and you can't go
any further you've actually only tapped
into about 40 percent of what you're
truly capable of an eye to be
fundamentally true but pain is like a
muscle you know it's like you can
acclimate to it you can you can get used
to it and your benchmark for tolerable
versus intolerable will shift I see that
more in my personal life and how far I'm
willing to push myself and how much risk
I'm willing to take to to do something
like when we were making minimalism I
would work 10 to 12 hours a day knowing
that this is this is a short stint like
this is at my sprint this is my marathon
I'm gonna be doing this for three months
and I'm gonna bust my ass and I'm gonna
sacrifice a lot I'm gonna I'm not gonna
go out I'm gonna work weekends but I
need to make this happen because if I do
half is huge the upside is tremendous
like if you really rocked it you knew
like that could change your life I did I
kind of know I I think what I I think
what my mentality was this could really
help people like this could change
people's lives I don't know if I was
thinking five people or ten million
people I didn't know what the scale
would be I didn't honestly didn't think
it would be as big as it was I didn't we
didn't think we'd be on Netflix we
didn't think anybody would really watch
the film we're like oh we'll just share
it with our small community of people
that really are into minimalism one of
the reasons I started the podcast is
because a lot of people have a
misconception about what went in to
making the documentary they think there
was 20 people on set and especially when
they see catalyst films and spire media
bring you this production
I'm catalyst like it's just me I'm
trying to just share the light that
people can go out there and make this
stuff everybody has the the opportunity
to do it and what I'm trying to do is
inspire people to make the meaningful
content because it's a lot of stuff out
there it's kind of vapid and people
weren't really folk
hang on the intent behind it why I'm
making it is that actually going to make
an impact yeah a couple observations on
that the first is I love what you said
about creating meaningful content and as
I'm kind of trying to inch inch my way
into this video space that's really my
marching orders like you know like does
anybody really need to see another vlog
like how can i how can I create content
that actually is a is is helpful and can
last you know over time and has
substance to it you know that's harder
to do but ultimately like if you're not
doing that then what are you doing
secondly you said something very
interesting which is when you were
making the movie that you were really
focused on on this idea of how it could
help people and I think that that's a
beautiful sentiment because service is
the ultimate renewable energy source
like when you're coming from that place
from the heart where you're like I'm
really here to try to convey something
that I think can be a benefit to other
people that's what gets you through the
adversity you know that's what's gonna
allow you to show up for it day after
day after day when you're facing
obstacles and I found that the more that
I'm in that service mindset of like how
am i helping people that's what not only
keeps me going but keeps me excited and
also you know gives me the that extra
boost when you're when you're tired and
you don't want to do it or you're faced
with an obstacle that you don't think
you can get over you know and I think
it's the secret to success if you can
find a way to do something that you're
passionate about filmmaking and tie that
to service in a meaningful way
that's when doors fly open and that's
when you know the universe again you
know shows up to conspire to support you
you can slip up to when like you said
it's not a straight line with a lot of
this stuff and even now building the
podcast and doing certain things you
start to get caught up and looking at
the metrics and be like okay how many
followers do I have and you know how
much is my growth over the past three
months but and what is
that iTunes algorithm and why is it
always screwing me yeah exactly and but
it doesn't matter like that's not gonna
affect you literally if you didn't look
at any of the comments you didn't look
at any of the your views or you just
kept putting stuff out and put a
blindfold on I feel like you'd be way
better off and you're more likely to
make something stick because you don't
care about what people are saying you're
just you're just trying to help
you know I'm competitive I'm an athlete
like so all I'll be just as competitive
when I'm looking at the metrics of the
pie and and I have to rely cono that's
not what this is about and it's not
necessarily about how many people are
listening or trying to get as many
people to listen as possible it's about
how can I be of maximum service to the
people that are already turning in
tuning in who are who are already on
this wavelength who want to hear from me
I have to serve those people and if I'm
in that heart space and I'm in that
service minded mentality then ultimately
that's that's the secret to growing it
anyway right when you can like stop
looking at all of that and stop being
influenced by what other people are
doing and like while he's doing that so
I should do that like you got to like
cut that off and just focus on okay what
do I bring nobody is nobody is you there
are other people with podcasts that are
interviewing people but nobody is used
so how can you bring more of you into it
and your aesthetic and Sensibility and
the issues that you care about most and
ultimately you know that that audience
will gravitate towards you and your job
is to take care of them why did you
start your podcast I had become a fan of
the medium in training for all these
races because when you're out on an 8
hour bike ride you can't listen to music
the whole time I was listening to
audiobooks and then I started listening
to podcasts and I really fell in love
with the format and I couldn't
understand why everybody wasn't
listening to them I was like this is
great like there's and at that time you
know the herd was pretty thin like there
were some great shows but it kind of
dropped off like there wasn't a lot of
depth right so there were great you know
there were shows that exist now they're
still big like Joe Rogan was doing his
thing and you know a lot of comedy shows
very comedy heavy you know NPR tons of
stuff but I just got really into it and
I was like wow I can program my entire
day around all
audio / like I don't why am i listening
to the radio why am i letting somebody
else tell me what I should be listening
to I can design my own experience here
and I thought it was amazing and I
learned so much I'd be out riding my
bike and I I'd be you know I'd be
feeding my mind at the same time but I
also was like the only person that I
knew that was listening to them like
it's just not that many people were hip
to it but my book came out in 2012 and
that chopped it was like okay well that
happened like what are you gonna do now
and and it was this thing where I was
kind of like this is gonna be my big
moment like I walked away from the law
and I realized like okay this book like
it it can it can come and go like so
most books do it'll be a flash in the
pan for a minute and then everyone moves
on but if I really like invest myself
and and really hustle my butt off like
maybe I can use this as a way to change
my life so that's why I was like I
didn't renew my bar membership I was
like I'm going all-in and I did it and I
did as much as I could you know in the
situation where I was in at that point
which is that not many people knew who I
was to get it out there and it did okay
it wasn't like a New York Times
bestseller or anything like that I had a
little following but once that that kind
of PR moment passed it's like well now
what you know and I was like is anybody
gonna call like you know like the phone
wasn't ringing and I was like and and we
were running out of money and it was
like a it was a scary moment and
ultimately I moved my family to Hawaii
for three months and we lived on an
organic farm because there's a an
entrepreneur there who was trying to
create this conscious community and he
wanted my advice and and he paid our
family to do that which was like the
only money and like it was a godsend
because like we didn't there was no
money coming in but when I was there I
also had a lot of free time and I was
getting island fever I was feeling I was
like I worked so hard to like create a
connection with people now I'm on this
island I felt a million miles away from
people and I was starting to get jittery
about it I was like I need to do
something like I need a creative outlet
like the book stone what am i doing now
and I was like I'm just gonna maybe I'll
start a podcast like I love the medium
maybe I could do this and you know I
just my son's are musicians so we had
mics and we had a soundboard and I
watched Pat
video tutorial on how to start a podcast
and he walked me through the whole thing
like if Pat Flynn didn't have that I
don't know if you watch those videos but
he has like a step-by-step like here's
what you do it's easier now than it used
to be like there's all this weird stuff
that it's like it's this is actually
harder to get configured than you would
think it should be easier than this had
those videos not existed I don't know if
I ever would have been able to figure it
out on my own but I just did everything
that he said and hit record on this
first podcast my wife and I and we just
started talking and I had a blast and I
remember saying in that very first
episode like this is not a triathlon
podcast I have a vision for what I think
would be cool here and to this day it's
really kind of it has remained true to
that sentiment but I didn't know if I
was going to do a second one but it was
a thrill to like create something and
put it out in the world and there
weren't that many people that listened
to the first one barely any but enough
where I was like let's do it again I
think I did we did the second one like a
day later you know I was like I'll just
do this every day
yeah but but it was it was so early on
in the podcast world that that iTunes
DES shot it right to the top of the
health rankings so from day one like I
had visibility and then that got people
that got me traction you know I think if
I was starting it today we have a very
different story
but I was it I was it's like the one
time in my life where I was like at the
right doing the right thing at the right
moment and I was a little bit ahead of
the curve and that allowed me to make a
little bit of a land grab and people
started to listen and you know stuck in
Kauai so I was like who can I talk to
you know like who's here and I so I had
to do some Skype stuff and it's just a
ball I mean oh you know my early
episodes are so imperfect and so flawed
I can't even imagine going back and
listening to them I would cringe but I
just kept going you know and it got
better and I got I got I got better at
listening and better at asking questions
and you know as the audience grew it got
easier to get interesting people to talk
to me and it's really just been this
organic you know nonlinear journey that
I've been on that has taken me you know
on this path that I would have never
expected I like how you started how you
didn't overthink it you just click
record the kids made an amazing opening
track though yeah well they're very
they're very gifted it's funny cuz that
theme song was they did it in like 15
minutes and I was like alright this will
be a temp track you know and state it's
the same one you saw right it's really
good though I was surprised holy [ __ ]
there are your very talented musicians
they're about to release their first
album oh wow that's amazing yeah but
yeah we did it in a warehouse with like
you know mics that you use for guitar
like the wrong there we sit echo I was
like the worst building ever heard of
records like the ceiling was like 50
feet high yeah concrete floor and you
know whatever but it wasn't perfect and
you start it and you just keep you kept
making them yeah and the lesson there is
like you know just just start you don't
have to I didn't know what I was doing I
didn't know where I think a lot of
people hamstrung them hamstrung
themselves and paralyzed themselves
because they want all the answers before
they began they want to know what is the
ultimate running shoe that I need before
they ever go out and run or what's the
GPS watch that I need or what's the
camera you know like everyone like
you're Casey talking about us all the
time like people get so caught up in the
cameras like you have a phone like go
out and make a video if you want to be a
filmmaker like it's never been easier
all these tools are you know at our
fingertips now but we get scared and so
we hide behind the gear or the nut or
that the questions as an excuse to not
just begin
sometimes it paralyzes to make someone I
want this episode to be the best episode
I've ever made right and like otherwise
I'm not releasing it but then I think
alright like future Matt he's a thousand
episodes in this one it's not that big
of a deal just release it move on to the
next one release it move on to the next
one and the doing of it will tell you
what it wants to be you know it's like
you can't answer that question of what
it is until you begin doing it and it's
like a living thing like it will evolve
and it will it will tell you where it
wants to go you do all your podcasts in
person now right mm-hmm what was that a
conscious decision to say yeah alright
like I'm not doing Skype anymore yeah I
mean I did some Skype interviews early
on and and some of them are fine and
some of them were just dictated by
geography and things like that but I
realize like in thinking like what am i
what am i bringing to this that's
different or unique and I realized that
like my sweet spot or where
where I excel is is really emotionally
connecting with my guests and as
somebody who you know when I write write
a book or or or get interviewed when I
do Skype interviews with people you know
it's like I don't know who this person
is and I forget about it five minutes
later and for me like the podcast
journey for me is like I'm interviewing
people that that I want in my life like
these are people that like I want to
know and and for me the emotional
connection is paramount it's more
important than the information being
conveyed and I need to be with that
person and there's something about
locking eyes and sitting across from
somebody and engaging with them for 90
minutes to two hours to three hours at
times where that's an experience that
that person is not going to forget you
know and it means something you know
it's this long-form conversation is a
lost art form and it's just not
something that we do in our daily lives
like I had a this my friend Mishka she
Bali was over at my house yesterday we
he's been on my podcast like six times
he's like my body and our friendship
he's like I think we spent more time
podcasting than than just being friends
outside of podcasting but and that
sounds weird but at the same time it's
like well if we just hung out and went
out to eat would we have had a
conversation of this quality and depth
that's one thing I wouldn't yeah and
that's one thing I've been wanting to do
is just to sit my parents down and have
a conversation with them and like record
that and just one-on-one to because I'm
like when's the last time we just sat
down and I asked them questions about
their life and about their childhood I
want to do that with all my family and
friends like not to post it not for
anybody else but have I say austerity
yeah for my kids I thought about that
very same thing and there's something
about the formality of it like if
there's a mic in front of them and they
feel like they have to answer the
question yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
great there's something to about the
constraint you're creating a constraint
on yourself you are limiting you're
limiting yourself in some way because
you could interview anybody if you were
doing it remotely if you were just doing
it through Skype you could probably have
a thousand episodes at this point if it
was
that way but that constraint it it
creates it makes your podcast what it is
mm-hmm and it makes you get a little bit
more inventive about what you bring to
the table force like when you're making
a documentary or a narrative film and
you have a limited budget you can look
at that as a hindrance but ultimately
the that constraint provides you with
it's like the limitations push your
creative boundaries right so you have to
be creative in order to make it work and
that's where some you allow for the
magic to come in
what kind of prep do you put into your
interviews I had a learning curve with
that like I like to be very prepared but
I also think one thing that I've learned
is you can be too prepared
if you've read every article and you've
read every book you're probably going to
be fuelled with a lot of great questions
and you're gonna sound really smart to
the listener because they'll know that
you'll be you'll be it's like I read you
know I when you said this like you don't
be like wow that guy's prepared yeah but
I found that when you're too prepared
and you already know the answer to every
question that you're gonna ask because
they've answered it somewhere else that
it creates a little bit of a staleness
in the conversation it's like oh here's
the part where he's gonna say this you
know as opposed to purposely not doing
as much research as you could so that
you can be surprised because I think
when you're surprised there's a level of
engagement when you're listening and
you're like oh wow really like let's
explore that and then you're you it
keeps the energy and the intrigue and
the interest level higher so I try to
read the books of the guests that I have
on that have books sometimes that means
skimming them or listening to most of it
on audiobook whatever I can't you know I
can't read every single book I read a
couple articles and then I spend time
jotting out not necessarily questions
but like topic headings or areas that I
want to explore and then you know have a
little notebook just like you and I put
it out in front of me and I never
got it hmm you know it feels weird to
break eye contact a limit but also also
I think it's good to like put all of
that in your consciousness and then
forget it and then just show up and be
present and I think if you've done the
homework and you can be present and
you're listening then you're not gonna
struggle for what the next question is
gonna be or where to take the
conversation I'm still like a neurotic
person where I I have to be over
prepared for something and I think
that's one of those things that I can
get better at is just letting go and
letting go of expectations of what
something is gonna be and just I
remember when we met which was at Josh
and Ryan's event I think it was in San
Francisco you said something about the
way that people interview and it's like
okay great cool awesome
next question and it's as always next
question next question and it has their
list of questions and they're not paying
attention they're not present and
they're not listening
they're just intent on getting through
their list of questions and as soon as
they feel like the person's answered
that they're like awesome and the next
one it's like that's not a conversation
and that's a very one-sided non dynamic
way of interacting with somebody do you
think are a lot of people talk about our
attention span and that we have such a
short attention span now it's all about
the 140 characters do you think that
we're starting to get tired of that and
sick of the sound bytes people just want
to hear a real conversation in context
yeah I think that's a big reason why
podcasting has exploded it's so
refreshing because it's the polar
opposite of the tweet right like what
you're gonna talk to this guy for a
couple hours like that is that flies in
the face of all other forms of media
from news local and national news to
sitcoms or whatever kind of content that
you're consuming everything has gotten
shorter and shorter and shorter and I
think the podcast represents a pendulum
swing backwards to something that's real
that is that has depth and emotion and I
think there's something in our in our
spirit that yearns for that it's like
story
telling is as old as as as man right and
podcasting is a way of storytelling in a
way that allows it to breathe you know
and I think there's also this yearning
for authenticity right and in you know
you put these conversations up like
they're imperfect they're not edited
they're not drilled down to sound bites
and if you spend a couple hours with
somebody it's intimate and that person
is ultimately gonna reveal who they are
there's something real about it there's
something honest about it that I think
is also quite refreshing and I think
that's why people are connecting with
the media when we talk to Juliette short
for minimalism she talked about that
word authenticity and it's funny because
brands and advertising companies they
have hijacked that term and they try to
they want their brand of their company
to feel authentic I think it is rare to
find real authenticity but when you find
it you you know that it's there and you
can't fake it in the long run you can
fake it in a 30 second advertisement by
in a two-hour conversation I don't think
you can fake authenticity yeah the word
has definitely been co-opted and
commodified and I understand why because
people realize like oh that is important
and that's what people respond to but
the immediate the the minute that you
can modify it it's no longer what it is
like I feel like we need a new word now
it's like it's like a bad word to say
authentic but true authenticity like
transcends that and and there is a
difference and I think people are
getting wiser and wiser and more more
discerning when it comes to [ __ ] you
know what I mean like what young person
watches an advertisement you know it's
like we our radar is so highly attuned
to what's real and fake and what's
honest that the attempt to manufacture
authenticity and some kind of branding
message
it's just isn't going to fly especially
with young people there they see right
through that like you know when it's
real mm-hmm
somebody might look you and say you've
gotten to a point where you can just
to sit back and relax but you're still
put in some long hours you're posting
videos close to midnight how do you find
that the balance between the podcast the
running and the training and the eating
and all this it's it's hard you know I I
would say that that on a day to day
basis I'm not a balanced person you know
on a six month to six month basis I am
very balanced like I make sure that all
the important areas of my life are well
attended to but I worked my ass off man
and you know the podcast is a lot of
work if you want to do it if you want to
create if you want to create something
special
that's not ephemeral you know you have
to you know this so somebody who's
attentive to design and aesthetics and
detail like it's not easy right it
requires a tremendous amount of my
attention in time and I have people now
that are helping me but it's still
ultimately it's me it's my voice like I
write I try to write a really nice blog
post that goes and goes with it each
episode and I want to design the page so
it looks just so and all that stuff
requires a tremendous amount of
attention I travel all the time I'm
doing public speaking I'm also trying to
train I'm a dad too for kids like I'm
juggling a lot of different things and
you know trying to step into the video
stuff now is like when I'm supposed to
be writing books and like you know it's
like it's a lot you know and I know how
to work hard like I don't think I'm the
most talented person out there but but
but I know how to like I do have a high
pain tolerance and I do know how to work
hard and and I'm not afraid to you know
but I think also a lot of that drive is
informed by the fact that like I didn't
figure out what I wanted to do with my
life until I was in my mid-40s
you know and I'm 51 now how long am I
gonna be able to do that like I got a I
got a make you know I got a you know I
got to make hay now so I'm highly
motivated to make sure that I'm
maximizing the opportunities that I'm
blessed you know have come across my
radar these days but I also you know I
also have to take care of myself it's
like the adage like there's so much
wellness in my life I'm getting sick you
know yeah you know I have to be careful
because I have to be an ambassador and a
living
example of these ideas that i'm that i
that i espouse i find the hardest thing
to do is when you're pressing towards a
deadline and making sure that all those
things are in check because there's
sometimes I have to push everything else
to the side to focus on this one thing
say for a month or two months like this
is all I can focus on because once I get
into something I'm not gonna be
satisfied until it's finished and until
I'm done I'm not a multitasker I'm
somebody who likes to go all-in on
something so I hear you completely man
and and I used to feel like like guilty
about that like but I've changed my
perspective on that like that's I think
that's a gift you know and I don't think
we should feel bad about that like
there's a guy called Brad Stolberg I
talked who writes for outside and he
wrote a book called peak performance and
we've had long conversations about this
and he's he said I'm paraphrasing but he
says something like look the times in my
life where I feel most alive are the
times when I'm fully invested in
something that I care about you know and
and and the passerby would say well
that's you're out of balance like
whether you're training for an ultra
marathon or you're writing a book or
you're editing a documentary where you
just have to go into the cave and
immerse yourself in a world our culture
sort of tells us well that's you're out
of you're out of whack with that you
gotta you know you gotta bring it back
but it's like if that's your thing man
like let it fly like go for it you know
that pendulum will have to swing back
but it's okay to be out of balance when
it's something that you're passionate
about as long as you know there's not
you know people aren't getting
sacrificed in the cross hairs of that so
I've learned to like really embrace that
like that's you know people will say to
me you're just you you you're channeling
these alcoholic tendencies and you're
running or into these other things and I
think it's in all fairness like I can't
dismiss that I'm like yeah there's
probably some truth to that
so should I beat myself up about that or
is that okay like I used to feel like
maybe I am maybe do maybe I do have an
alcoholic relationship with this or that
but these things are making my life
better and there
helping other people I'm like no man
this is like what I'm here to do I'm
gonna feel good about it
alright I do bring up the rock and every
podcast because I don't know if you saw
I have the rock oh right over your
shoulder right there
original photo with the turtleneck yeah
so getting the rock on my podcast is my
big goal it's my stretch goal it's like
my dream right somebody that's that's
really inspiring to me in terms of a
ground up story he's somebody who's just
built it from nothing if you were to
give me advice on how I could get the
rock on my podcast what would you say
well let's just call him and ask him we
could call him yeah I don't have his
phone number that's the kind of thing
where you put the you you put that
intention out into the world and you let
people know obviously you bring public
about it and and the way that something
like that will happen will be in a way
that you can't predict or imagine it's
not gonna happen because you call his
agent and his agent and eBooks it like
it's never gonna happen that way it's
gonna happen because you know somebody
who who knows somebody who's just cousin
or you'll bump into him at the right
time or somebody will know somebody and
that's how that's how it will eventually
come to be all right let's get into
quick questions rich where do you go
when you're feeling doubt what I'm
feeling doubt the best thing for me to
do is to go for a run or go for a swim
you know when I allow my unconscious
mind to take center stage and I can just
be present out on the trail at dawn or
in the water
and I can free-associate that's when I'm
able to be my most creative and
problem-solve without trying to
problem-solve
and that usually allows me to approach
things that I have doubt around or
confusion around with a greater sense of
clarity throughout all these years what
one skill have you leveraged in a way
you think other people haven't
resilience
what is the simplest advice that's the
most important to follow trust yourself
follow your heart
if you could only put three ingredients
into your Vitamix blender what would
they be an amazing combination is kale
and pineapple really you wouldn't think
that it would be good it's actually
delicious so you could just do those two
alone would be great if you're gonna add
a third maybe add some hemp seeds or
chia seeds about two more questions what
one thing should my audience read
Launcher listened to before they go to
bed or before they go to bed yeah
tonight there's a book called
autobiography of a yogi' by Paramahansa
Yogananda I've read like eight times and
it just blew my mind and has changed my
life and will expand expand your
consciousness and your horizons for what
you imagine is possible and last
question where should people connect
with you online pretty easy to find on
the internet I'm at rich roll on Twitter
and Instagram
is youtube-dot-com forward-slash patrol
but mostly ritual podcast on itunes or
wherever you listen to podcast cool man
thanks for doing this Thank You Man a
pleasure thanks for listening to the
ground up show if you like this podcast
there's something you can do right now
to help head on over to iTunes and leave
a quick review I print out every single
one and I put them up on my mood board
above my bed okay that's not true but I
still notice and appreciate every one
for more on the ground up show including
behind the scenes videos check out
ground up show calm thanks for listening